que j'ai juste dit rapidement je me me
je m'étonne encore une fois du succès de
cette émission pour a eu un objet vendu
intelligent l'autre jour j'ai regardé
peut-être pas de chance pour moi la
personne lors d une porcelaine qui
étaient fausses
le type dit c'est faux on commence les
anciens à 15 euros ça a été vendu à 27
il a accepté je me suis dit chantre de
regardant la télé avec pour une
porcelaine 27 euros dont certains cas
sont bien sûr changer les choses
y'a un mec il est il a un truc qui te
donne tu veux c'est paraît il aurait pu
le vendre 15 et le mans 27 elle pas été
pris pour les jeunes ados gisselmann ans
et non pas six cuit non on prend ça à
chaque fois n'a pas le temps de parler
ou pas mais pas très sérieux moi je ne
vous auriez jamais ça avec hanoune alors
que nathan a peu fait pas les choses à
faire j'ai voyagé j'ai une équipe j'ai
dit qu'il ya travaillé j'ai des infos
moi j'ai bossé contrairement à vous
ça y est
à propos d'un top chef c'est payé il a
été éliminé travaux alors attendez
attendez vous vous arrivez sa lutte
avant l'émission soit son lit en plus à
l'accusé mois